so when we name organic molecules the
the the core of what we think about is
just how many carbons form the chain or
form the ring that we're looking at so
let's say i have something like this and
hopefully you're reasonably familiar
with what this represents and i'll
review it a little bit so let's say i
have something like this
let's say that that is the molecular
structure right there and so the first
question you should be asking is how
many carbons are there there and you and
some of you might say wait how is that
even a molecule and just as a review the
end point of every line represents a
carbon so that's a carbon
that's a carbon that's a carbon that's a
carbon and that's a carbon that's a
carbon and we have one two three
four five
six carbons and we have no double bonds
so if you have all of that information
you're ready to name this molecule and
before i actually name it let me just
kind of give you all of the different
prefixes so if you have
one carbon
if you have one carbon the prefix is
meth
the prefix is meth if you have two
carbons the prefix is f and it's good to
memorize at least you know up to about
10 and actually it kind of repeats after
that if you have three carbons the
prefix is prop
probe like propane and you've heard of
ethane and methane so you'll see all of
that soon four you're talking about
butte
five and after five it kind of becomes
the the traditional prefixes that we
associate with a lot of these numbers so
at five it's pent like pentagon six it's
hex-like hecta hexagon seven is hept
eight is oct like octagon
nine is none
ten is dec
and then after that it kind of starts to
have a pattern here and you're not going
to really deal with things much beyond
the teens but i'll just write them down
here just out of interest 11
is
on deck
on deck and for those of you who know
french i'm not one of them but i know
that that that one in french is un or or
in spanish uno so it's kind of one and
ten eleven
twelve
is dodec
dodec do or dos if you're speaking
spanish for two deck for ten two and ten
that's twelve
thirteen you could imagine what it's
going to be it is tridek
tri-deck
fourteen
is
tetradek tetra
deck a tetrapod is something with four
legs and then after that becomes very
systematic at 15 is pentadeck
pentadeck notice pent pent 5 and 10. 16
is hexadeck
17 is heptadek so it just goes on and on
and on i don't think i have to go away
it's hexadeck heptadec octa deck is 18
19 is not a deck and then 20 is actually
iso but we won't even go into that this
will probably serve our purposes i mean
i could go up to you know 16 is hexadec
hexadec so this is just how many carbons
are in our longest chain what i drew
here is just one chain so we can
immediately
let's try to name it what how many
carbons do we have here well we have
one two three four five six carbons so
we'll be dealing with hex as a prefix
and then to get i guess the postfix on
this prefix or the kind of the root you
look to see if there are any double
bonds here and there are no double bonds
here and if we have no double bonds in
this carbon chain we're dealing with an
alkane
this is called an alkane which is a
general term for all of the chains of
carbons that have no double bonds on
them or no triple bonds all single bonds
so in this situation you take hex for
six so this is hex
and then because it's an alkane it gets
the ain from alkane so this is hex
this is hexane let's do another one
let's say i have this thing right here
i'll draw
let's make it even longer so let's say i
have that thing right there so how many
carbons do we have we have one two
three four
five six
seven carbons they're all single bonds
so it's an alkane so this will be we
seven carbons it is hept
heptane because we all have we have all
single bonds now if things form a chain
we or if things form a ring i should say
we put it we put the prefix cyclo in
front of it so if i have let me show you
what i'm talking about
so if i just have five carbons
one two
three four so one two three four five
okay so that's five right there one two
three four five carbons in a chain if i
just have five carbons in a chain like
this this would be pentane
pentane
pentane but if i have five carbons then
they form a ring so let me draw it so
it's one two three four
five carbons and it forms a ring
let me make it a little bit let me make
the drawing a little bit better
so it's really i'm just drawing a
pentagon but notice this has five
carbons on it i could draw the carbons
here
carbon carbon carbon carbon carbon and
just as a review what you don't see is
the hydrogens they're bonded to each of
these guys have two bonds so they must
have two bonds with something else and
those are going to be with hydrogens and
i'll draw it here just as a bit of a
review but you notice very quickly the
drawing gets extremely messy when you
draw the two hydrogens on each of these
carbons so it's a little bit
over maybe i shouldn't be doing that but
there you go so it becomes very messy
when you draw the hydrogen so it's
better to just assume that they're there
if we don't draw all four bonds on the
carbon the other two bonds are going to
be with hydrogen so here you might say
okay this is an alkane because i don't
have any double bonds here all of these
are single bonds with the carbon i have
five carbons you might say this is
pentane but you have to think about one
more thing it's in a ring so we add the
prefix cyclo to it so this is because
it's a ring we write
cyclo
cyclopentane
cyclopentane so let me just break that
apart this tells us that we're dealing
with
a ring you see that this is a ring right
there
this tells us
this tells us that we're dealing with
five five carbons
and then this tells us right here the
ain't part that tells us that they are
all single bonds
all
carbon-carbon single bonds no double or
triple bonds
all single bonds so let's go the other
way let's let's start with the word and
let's see if we can figure out what the
actual structure would look like so
let's say i have
let me let's say i have
cyclocyclonane
cyclone so what is this telling me this
tells me i'm dealing with a ring
that is a ring it's going to have a ring
structure it's going to have nine
carbons nine c's and then it's an alkane
so they're all going to be single bonds
it's all going to be all going to be
single bonds
single
single bonds so if i want to draw it i
want to draw nine carbons in a ring it's
not a trivial thing to draw let me try
my best let's see that's one
two
one two three
uh four
five six
seven
eight
uh that's about
well let's see let me draw it let me try
a little a better
shot at it so let's have 1
1 2
and then 9 and then then you can connect
the last two so let me make sure that
this is and i obviously i could have
drawn it better than that but hopefully
you can see all the edges here so i have
one two three four five six
seven eight
nine carbon so that is
we have it's it's in a cycle it's in a
ring i have nine carbons they're all
single bonded so this is
cyclonine although there's probably
better ways to draw that ring right
there so if someone were to tell you if
i someone would tell you octane
octane
if someone were to tell you octane and
that word might
feel familiar to you from the gas
station they are literally talking about
the molecule octane and now you know or
at least you have a sense of what
they're talking about the oct
tells you that you have
eight carbons
there are there is no cyclo in front of
it so it's not a cycle it's just going
to be a chain and then the ain't part
tells you that they're all single bonds
so it's just going to be eight carbons
in a chain
one two
three four five six seven eight it's
just gonna look like that one two three
four five six
seven eight in the next few videos we'll
add more to these molecules and make the
names even more complex